the number of confirmed deaths from
coronavirus infections in the uk has
topped 150 000 it's the highest recorded
death toll in any european nation as the
total of omicron cases in the uk surges
ever higher the health care system is at
full stretch
ambulances waiting to deliver patients
to a hospital in north london
there's no space inside because all the
beds are occupied by covet 19 sufferers
how long have you been waiting in the
ambulance for
i've probably said maybe an
hour i mean it is frustrating because i
want to go in there
britain's hospitals are under pressure
from record numbers of omicron
infections
around 1 in 15 people in england are
thought to have coveted 19.
in london the ratio is even higher
our ward is a 35-bedded board which was
purpose-built during the pandemic to
look after patients with covet
currently our ward is full and it's full
with all patients with cohord
most of those needing hospital treatment
have not been vaccinated against the
coronavirus
this woman now wishes she had been
i should have listened to all my like
family and friends because everybody
else has had it it's just me
did you feel like you were going to die
i did
i must have been terrified before i even
got here at home when the ambulance came
up i was on my last breath my oxygen was
below 70.
yeah so i was quite close to death many
blame those who for whatever reason have
not had the vaccine
what they don't understand is that they
it isn't just a question of protecting
themselves they're being selfish because
they're taking up beds that need not be
taken up and that is putting more
pressure on the health service
staff shortages are a big problem
many doctors and nurses are off sick
with the virus themselves
some hospitals have had to call in the
army to plug the gap left by absent
medical workers
but there are signs of hope
health authorities say the number of
omicron infections in london may now be
past its peak
for more let's bring in our
correspondent charlotte chelsea pill in
london charlotte 150 000 lives lost to
covet 19. how are people reacting to
this
clearly a very somber milestone here in
the uk and of course there are different
ways of measuring this death toll one
suggesting that it could in fact be even
higher
clearly extremely uh tragic this
milestone now now the prime minister has
released a statement on twitter he said
that coronavirus has taken what he
called a terrible toll on our country he
said each and every one of those who
died as a profound loss to the families
friends and communities affected and he
took the moment to really stress how
getting the booster jab getting the
first and second vaccine is really the
path out of this pandemic now there has
of course been criticism over through
the course of the pandemic over the
government's handling of this crisis and
a spokesperson for the campaign group
bereaved families for justice which
supports families who've lost loved ones
to covert has been very critical of this
milestone they have said that
public inquiry into the government's
handling of the pandemic cannot come
soon enough
all of this questioning charlotte as the
country is also combatting a wave of
omicron infections how are hospitals
coping
there's no doubt that the health service
here is under immense pressure at the
moment
hospitalizations and fatalities have
started
rising here and what's very clear is
they were already dealing with a backlog
the effects of months of this pandemic
with hospitalizations now rising winter
pressures and crucially staff absences
fueled by this omicron variant this is a
critical time for the health service
at the moment as you mentioned earlier
here in london the military 200 military
personnel have been sent in to try and
support the health service although of
course that will do
will not compensate for the sheer number
of staff who are absent or isolating at
the moment
you know as we heard in the report
authorities are hopeful because they
believe omicron infections may be past
their peak how would they get to that
conclusion specifically
it is extremely early days for that last
week we saw record case numbers over 200
000 here in the uk the last couple of
days
have seen a bit of a dip on that
extremely high figure but as i say very
early days to be saying that the uk is
past the peak you have to look at this
regionally of course here in london
perhaps case numbers aren't as high as
they were other parts of the country
they are going up and health experts
advisors to the government have warned
that what we will be particularly
crucial is what needs to be seen is a
reduction in cases in all age groups
particularly older age groups who we
know
are most vulnerable to this virus that's
a charlotte chelsea pill in london for
us many thanks
you